dans cette salle de l'atrium plusieurs
centaines de jeunes des lycéens des
enseignants également en face les
invités historiens notamment des jeunes
à la découverte de la sphère andré
aliker et sur grand écran c'est d'abord
le professeur jean claude williams qui
raconte l'enquêté confiée au juge t il à
faire le chemin du chemin a dit andré
aliker journalistes du journal justice
militant communiste assassiné le 12
janvier 1934 retrouvé mort ligoté sur la
plage de fond boulet à case-pilote un
crime qui bouleverse la martinique un
assassinat mais pas d' assassin je
connaissais le lycée mais vous pas
vraiment son histoire ça existe est
quelqu'un d'important il connaissait pas
du tout son étoile que franchement c'est
vraiment dommage qu'on ne trouve pas son
assassin mais que c'est un homme quand
même car ici à se battre
même s'il y manque que la justice soit
qu'aux mondiaux il établit que le
journalisme cuisse
avoir une voix mais punk aux mondiaux
qu'on pût c'est un homme bien qui la
travaillent pour la vente unique et il
faut arrêter les gens qui l'ont
assassiné le contexte social économique
et politique des années 30 est difficile
il y a le pouvoir et l'argent
il y a aussi le pouvoir de l'argent
passez-vous d'actualité les pouvoir et
argent sont deux jours ci de là il faut
de toute façon multiplié ses actions à
faut que nos élèves que nos enfants
d'aujourd'hui puissent se rendre compte
de ce qui s'est passé au début du siècle
dernier comprendre lieu notre vie que
marquer les temps forts de notre
histoire
au programme culturel de la ctm d'autres
personnages emblématiques de la
martinique reste donc à découvrir des
hommes et des femmes qui ne figure pas
encore dans les livres d'histoire de
cette génération